salut toute cette semaine j'étais au
café théâtre la fontaine d'argent à aix
en provence j'ai joué là six
représentations d'affilée et aujourd'hui
on est dimanche et 17h30 je vais jouer
ma dernière représentation oui je sais
tu verras pas cette vidéo dimanche vous
la mettre juste la semaine prochaine
pour une fois que j'ai un petit décalage
alors dans l'équipe en temps normal il
ya jacques et fabienne mais ils sont pas
là et bien tant pis pour jacky flavienne
c'est ceux qui tiennent ce lieu et moi
aujourd'hui je suis avec lorraine et de
la billetterie elisabelle et de la
billetterie ou du stage et sylvain notre
régisseur bonjour je vais essayer une
mentalisation mitraillette sur ces trois
personnes c'est à dire que comme je vous
ai rencontré toute la semaine qui peut
on a discuté tous les jours et toute ma
vie je suis peut-être capable de
détecter quand est-ce que vous mentez ou
pas peut-être je sais pas c'est la
première fois que mentale blog que
j'essayais sur trois personnes en même
temps je vais vous donner un petit bout
de papier
on va on va détruire un des flyers mais
c'étaient les flyers pour ici donc comme
c'est la dernière juste elle ne l'aurait
tuée dans ta main pour l'instant je
dispute la presse deuxième lieu au lit
car pour toi
d'ailleurs le journaliste poursuit
demain je me retournais pour savoir si
vous allez faire vous allez mettre les
mains dans votre dos et chacun donne pas
ses coûts dans sa main droite ou dans sa
même ensuite je vais vous poser une
question
vous avez décidé de me mentir ou de dire
la vérité qui vous dites la vérité en
faire on a faim avant de me rejoindre
pour passer soit trop facile et donc
seul devant vous mettez la mollesse dans
une des deux mains et vous ne bougez pas
décrocher bon vous avez vu on a une
petite coupure mais c'est normal ça
dépend des réservations je veux vous
regardez bien les mains quand c'est fait
vous me dit c'est bon c'est bon non
cotées alors je me retourne je bougeais
plus vous avez déterminé
individuellement dans le xiii qui vous
allez dire la vérité tout si vous aviez
menti
le renne est-ce que la boulette et dans
ta main droite non d'accord elizabeth ii
c'est le volet 2 ans à ma droite non
plus il pense que vous l'avez noté 3 oui
oui
allez je dirais gauche droite gauche
pour moi gauche droite gauche
azita l'heure ça m'agace ouais tout le
temps je ne suis pas au début alors
c'est ça la france
lors donc en soit on veut dire que le
récit sans il s'est auto mentaliser
parce qu'en fait je suis auto bleue fait
et ils savaient même pas lui même qui
mentaient il monte parce que j'ai réussi
et j'ai réussi sur toile et j'ai réussi
sur toi et donc je considère que j'ai
fait
il va bien falloir que j'essaye de faire
sur trois personnes en même temps donc
c'était merci pour toute cette semaine
j'étais super bien accueilli et
s'écoulent et j'espère qu'on trouvera
pour roder le nouveau spectacle
comme quoi vous auriez dû aussi venir me
voir en spectacle mais il ya d'autres
dates de toute manière pensez à vous
abonner à la chaîne à mettre un petit
pouce en l'air un commentaire tout ça ça
fait plaisir
et rendez vous demain à 11 heures pour
le prochain mentale blog ciao